muy buenos días Raúl pues desde aquí
desde Río de Janeiro Aunque el ambiente
está tranquilo se puede respirar la
polarización a las puertas de este
debate final antes de ir a las urnas
está previsto justo aquí en esta ciudad
en los estudios de la televisión
una de las más importantes del país su
globo donde los dos candidatos el de
ultraderecha y el de izquierda tendrán
el último encuentro y está previsto que
se debatan cinco bloques en total dos
eran de temas libres y cada uno Tendrá
15 minutos en cada bloque para
administrarlos como mejor crea y está
previsto también que sea bolsonaro el
que de inicio a este debate final todo
en medio de una campaña como hemos visto
muy sucia en la que el Tribunal Superior
electoral ha tenido que intervenir para
intentar suprimir todas estas
informaciones falsas que circulan por
internet y por redes sociales que han
llegado a equiparar a bolsonaro con un
caníbal y a Luis Lula da Silva con
Aliado de Satanás básicamente sí Alba
también toquemos un tema delicado porque
el presidente Yair bolsonaro estaría
allanando el camino entonces para
desconocer los resultados electorales de
este domingo que se dice en Brasil
Sí justo hemos tenido unas acusaciones o
el Tribunal Superior electoral sobre
todo está señalando a bolsonar o porque
hace poco Hace unos días él mismo
intentó señalar a una radios de El
nordeste del país que es una región
clave en disputa entre Lula y bolsonaro
y dijo que estaban suprimiendo
básicamente sus campañas con con motivo
de la campaña básicamente no estaban
emitiendo su campaña y pasó al tribunal
superior electoral y este dijo que no
había indicios de que esas acusaciones
fueran ciertas y que lo que intenta es
en un estilo Halo Trump como han dicho
algunas Fuentes del periódico de
Sao Paulo intentará llenar el camino por
si acaso pierde en las elecciones del 30
de octubre